[Music]
good morning and welcome to trevor
phillips on sunday
the mists are clearing as most of the
country moves from plan b back to plan a
the masks are coming off at work and at
school and we can finally see the smile
as well as the frown on each other's
faces
abroad the mask may be slipping from the
inscrutable mr putin according to our
intelligence services russia plans to
install a puppet regime in ukraine the
foreign office has even named some of
its likely members normally nobody can
see what goes on behind the tory whips
closed doors but this morning a former
conservative minister accuses tory
disciplinarians of citing her muslim
faith as a reason for her sacking
usually they would respond tersely
you might say that but i couldn't
possibly comment but this time the chief
whip has outed himself to say that her
account is categorically untrue
and defamatory
and if all that openness isn't enough
for you sometime this week the veil
should be lifted on sue gray's long
anticipated report on party time in
downing street can't wait
let's see what more we can reveal during
the next 60 minutes
with this country facing another
invasion by russia and the world
stumbling into a dangerous and
intensifying east-west struggle will be
joined by ukraine's ambassador to the uk
uk vadim pristiko
the government here faces its own range
of threats from sue grey's report and
the political danger boris johnson
remains in to the rising cost of living
and looming tax rises so i'll talk to
deputy prime minister and justice
secretary dominic raab
and we'll get the view from labour from
shadow attorney general emily thornbury
with number 10 in seemingly perpetual
crisis we'll speak to a man who knows
what it's like to do that top job
former prime minister gordon brown who's
deeply concerned about a lack of aid for
afghanistan and with covert restrictions
eased in schools we'll speak to the
children's commissioner dame rachel de
souza
but first i'm joined by the deputy prime
minister and justice secretary dominic
raab good morning deputy prime minister
um
i start by
asking about what can only be described
as a truly extraordinary statement from
your old department foreign office
alleging that mr putin plans to install
what amounts of puppet regime in ukraine
what evidence do you have for that
well look the uh foreign secretary and
the foreign officers have come out uh
making it clear
what the designs of the russian
government are
we of course don't go into things like
sources but it's very clear there is a
concerted not just military buildup on
the border but threat to the uh
democracy the integrity of ukraine and i
think the the important point to note in
all of this is it's building up slowly i
think president putin and moscow have
had this habit of trying to take
advantage of opportunities when the
world's attention is perhaps elsewhere
and the foreign secretaries quite
rightly pointing to the designs that
russia has and we're saying really two
things first of all ukraine is a free
country uh under international it should
decide its own fate uh we will support
them in defending themselves but also to
the international community european uh
nato allies the us uh we're standing
shoulder shoulder saying there'll be
very serious consequences if russia
takes this move to try and invade but
also install a puppet regime okay well
if you know all of that you've obviously
prepared for the possibility of that
puppet regime and what are you going to
do about it well we
wouldn't telegraph all of the measures
that we would take but it's uh
important that this very clear message
not just from the uk but from all nato
and other uh interested uh countries
around the world who want to uphold the
rule of law that they'll be very serious
severe economic consequences and of
course ukraine will defend itself
well it will obviously involve a range
of financial and economic sanctions uh
we wouldn't telegraph those
in advance what you can rest assured uh
is that the foreign secretary of the
foreign office uh and the defense
secretary will be liaising with all of
our partners engaging and we have been
doing so uh for many months to make sure
that the response is robust and
concerted at the same time of course
what we really want is to get this
message so clearly to moscow that
president bhutan walks away from the
brink that is the off-ramp that we would
all like to see but let's let's be
concrete what what actually would you do
for example
swiss bank accounts
well as i said i i can give you the the
the areas i'm not going to go into all
the details not only because that's
countable okay would that be one area we
would look at the personal interests of
vladimir putin and his friends in the
kremlin well we already have and you'll
remember i introduced magnitsky
sanctions to allow asset freezes and
visa bans to be imposed not just for
human rights abuses but also for severe
corruption all the tools at our disposal
whether it's sexual financial economic
sanctions but also individual targeted
sanctions uh are up for are on the table
and of course we we the the two things
that the kremlin care about are would
they get
locked into a quagmire in ukraine i
think there's a very serious risk of
that but also will they suffer an
economic price and and of course things
like nordstrom 2 and what the europeans
are willing to do on that is going to be
critically important
in the hands of the germans and we don't
know what they'll do but i i'm very
interested in this point about um
the swiss and
we know about magnitsky but would you be
prepared for example to make the case
for the russians to be locked out of the
international banking system well i
certainly think financial sanctions
properly properly targeted and done in
concert with our major partners is
something that we would readily look at
is our government prepared
aside from all of the word for an
invasion of the ukraine
and were there to be a
an incursion major minor whatever
what would we do
would we send troops
i think it's extremely unlikely that we
would do that but what we have said is
that we are already willing and engaged
in training programs to support the
ukrainians defending themselves that's
absolutely right for defensive purposes
secondly as i made clear we want to make
sure that the economic cost to the
kremlin of doing so uh is sufficiently
severe that they think twice what we
want and the americans are obviously
engaged in the diplomacy liz trust the
foreign office are as well we want putin
to step back and realize how damaging
this would be for him let alone for
ukraine and the international community
okay before we move on i tried to ask
you
what might be a if you like a personal
question your
father fled czechoslovakia in 1938 yeah
after the munich agreement head of
hitler's invasion of the sudetenland
which most people now regard as a sort
of the paramount example of appeasement
that led to disaster
can you understand why this morning
people in ukraine might welcome your
words but still be absolutely terrified
that they will mean nothing to vladimir
putin
look i can
absolutely empathize with the plight of
the ukrainian people i think actually if
you look at what civil society and many
of the uh and indeed what the government
of ukraine is saying they're hugely
grateful for the forthright clear
sensible and calm but resolute response
that we've shown to them now ukraine is
not part of nato the self-defense the
collective self-defense provisions don't
apply but nonetheless it is a free
country that deserves to have its
integrity its direction
decided by its own people and we stand
shoulder to shoulder with them and all
other countries that want respect for
the international rule of law in doing
so
um this morning the former conservative
minister nazar ghani claims that her
muslim faith was cited as a reason for
her sucking it's a pretty serious
allegation
do you believe her well look i know
another and i've looked at that
allegation seen what she said it is
incredibly serious let me just be clear
at the outset we have absolutely zero
tolerance for any discrimination any
islamophobia in the conservative party
and you'll be familiar with the review
that was conducted by professor singh
just on these specific allegations it's
very unusual but the chief whip has come
out and said the conversation concerned
was with him this is mark spencer and
he's categorically denied it in what can
only be described as the most forthright
and robust terms indeed as you said
calling it defamatory the one point i
would note is that i think if there are
any claims like this they should result
in a formal complaint which allows a
formal investigation to take place and
as the chief whip has pointed out amnest
hasn't made a formal complaint she was
asked to do so this
relates back to 2020
um and in the absence of doing so uh
there will be no specific investigation
into this i get that but you're a lawyer
you're used to forensics
she says
he said this
he says
i didn't say it they cannot both be
right who do you believe yes but i'm not
going to get into that because i know it
gives a point yeah but but so trevor you
know what that gives is everyone a
headline was actually i want to tackle
the issue i think if there's any claim
like this a formal complaint should be
made and as the chief whipper said uh
that nuz was invited to make a formal
complaint she still is able to do so she
hasn't yet done so so i'm not going to
start getting into impugning anyone's
integrity that's not the business i'm in
i'm in the business of zero tolerance
for any islamophobia and a claim like
this as serious as it is should be
properly reported and then a proper
investigation okay so if she makes the
if she makes the uh formal complaint you
would favor a proper investigation oh i
think party i think the chief whip made
this clear back in 2020
all right
now look
this is just one more example i mean
on this particular thing it's it's
possible as
someone wise once said
um
that recollections might vary but this
is just one more issue that's dogging
the uh conservative party we started
talking
uh by talking about ukraine nothing
could be more serious
uh or dramatic than threat of war that's
not an issue dogging the conservative
party but let me finish let me finish my
question yeah the point is that um we
have to deal with what you yourself
called the soap opera in downing street
and squabbles and scandals this is
pretty poor government isn't it no i
don't actually if you look at this week
trevor the two big issues that will most
affect people up and down this country
is the fact that our vaccine rollout and
the booster uh campaign has been hugely
successful the prime minister got that
right over christmas and in the months
before a major decision and as a result
we've got over 80 percent of eligible
adults vaccinated that reduces the that
cuts the risk of hospitalization by 88
and if we'd have listened to the labor
party by the way whose manifesto was
calling for the nationalization of
pharmaceutical companies who wanted us
pegged to the eu
your colleague said that to me last week
i've got all well no but
there's a big thing that's happened this
week's trevor if i may so big decision
prime minister got it right kier has got
it wrong it hasn't taken the other big
thing is that we're coming through
locked down we're coming out of those
restrictions the economy fastest growing
in the g7 uh jobs are up wages are up
big call and back in july kistama said
it would be reckless so what i would say
to you when you challenge me with poor
the charge that the government is a
shambles and this that the other on the
two biggest decisions of the day coming
out this week it's topical prime
minister got it right kirsten got it
wrong yeah i didn't i didn't use the
word shambles i wouldn't be so rude but
my point is my point is very very
straight forward you might be you might
think this is the most important thing
indeed this program which deals with
these issues thinks it's in these things
are important but nobody is talking
about that what they are talking about
when i knock on doors come on in the
pubs in
in isha that's what they're talking
about with their greatest respect i was
out campaigning uh
last uh weekend this weekend and
actually people are asking about jobs
livelihoods the cost of living is a big
issue but of course if we'd have
listened to kia we wouldn't have been
out of lockdown hold on hold on hold on
wages are rising so all i'm just saying
is let's have some respect for all of
that so have some perspective because on
the big issues facing my constituents
the your viewers the country the prime
minister's got those big decisions right
kistama has got them wrong yeah and we
talk about the big issues all the time
but
let me put it this way some of my
colleagues would say
um you're a sky you keep going on about
these big things the only story that
matters and that we are hearing from our
viewers our readers and so on about is
the government's character the prime
minister's conduct let me put it to you
again yes i agree with you about these
big issues we we buy all of that the
problem is that you're as a government
paralyzed because you can't get past you
have to keep saying wait for sue gray
wait for that you can't get past that
issue yet well let me answer that
directly so yes of course it's the
distraction yes these are serious issues
yes sugree must decide them uh in a very
serious way but i would say this week
we've shown that we are dealing with the
big issues that we haven't been
distracted because we're being able to
ease up on the lockdown measures that
only happens because of the success of
the vaccine rolled out that only happens
because the prime minister held his
nerve when others including the labour
party were calling him to stay in
lockdown measures as a result fastest
growing economy in the g7 uh and
unemployment coming down finally enough
i mean just to give you a sense of big
picture unemployment is four percent
notwithstanding all that we've seen in
the pandemic that is half the level that
gordon brown who's coming on your show
left in 2010 yes
let's let's go there let's go to the
economy uh i agree with you it's the
biggest issue it is probably what they
are talking to you in the um
i don't know the weekly the prince of
wales whatever it is uh in your week is
my one of my local pubs there you go in
the wheat chief i bet you that they're
talking in between the gastro meals
they're talking about these things you
used to tell us
that the governments that delivered
runaway public spending soaring
inflation and tax rises were labor
administrations um are you proud that
your government's delivered all of those
things look i'm proud that in the eyes
of the worst pandemic probably the
biggest challenge we've seen
nationally probably globally since world
war ii
we've saved 15 million jobs through the
furlough scheme the vaccine rollout
scheme has not just saved
thousands of life it's the fastest in
europe we're the most tested in europe
and as a result of that the economy now
is getting back to the pre-pandemic
levels fast is growing in the g7 and
we're providing not just protection for
the lives but the livelihoods of people
up and down this country yes i am and
actually i don't take a theological view
of these things when you're in the eye
of the storm of the worst emergency
we've seen in living memory yeah but
you know you're saying we're coming back
to normal economy and so is good but as
i say
seven percent inflation public spending
soaring uh with the on housing uh energy
we're now going to see uh increases in
the proportion of our income spent on
energy because of rising prices for the
poorest 10 in this country housing costs
at 40 percent of their income is that is
that what the new normal is going to
look like not that's
that thrilling it's a totally fair
challenge so uh of course inflation is
rising uh but it will come down we're
putting 12 billion pounds of economic
support in this year extending the
personal allowance is something we've
done an extra thousand pounds for for
all workers the taper on universal
credit means that two million of the
lowest paid will get uh uh a further a
thousand pounds the winter fuel payments
the um the the various other measures
we're dealing uh the energy cap um
and all of those measures uh are there
to provide support for those uh on the
lowest incomes and who are feeling the
pinch but the one thing i wouldn't do is
nationalize the energy companies because
if you look uh which is what labour
proposed if you look at what the
confederation of british industry has
said that that would be hugely damaging
not just energy supply but it would hike
bills so again on the big issues we
under this prime minister under this
chance have got targeted measures at the
right calls in difficult times and
labor's approach will be an absolute a
disaster for for the very people you're
talking about you keep wanting to take
me back to the labour party that's fine
choices i'm going to choices trevor it's
all about decisions choices okay let me
deal with that with emily thornbury
let's focus on you my point that i'm
really trying to put you is we're faced
with thread of war
economic storm brewing potentially by
the way uh collapsed as a health service
because
uh all of the people who are not
vaccinated in health service going to be
sacked well i don't think that's true i
can't i can't accept that oh well let's
deal with that yeah it is thought that
73 000 of their about health staff will
be sacked because they haven't been
vaccinated royal college of uh general
practitioners chair today says uh could
you delay this
otherwise health service is going to
fall over what are you gonna do about
that so first of all there's a huge
package of support for the covered
recovery in the nhs we've got nine out
of ten nh staff nhs staff vaccinated
there's been a big push to encourage
vaccinations that's really important it
shows the progress that we've made and
we would encourage anyone to come
forward and get those jabs before the
deadline but we've also got to think
about the people will be at risk if uh
if nhs staff don't have the vaccine and
just just on resilience we've got almost
5 000 more doctors almost 11 000 more
nurses than we did in 2020 precisely to
provide the support so i'm afraid i just
don't accept on the facts that challenge
all right well look before we finish i i
must just come back to this point you
know i've mentioned um we've met i've
never mentioned sue gray too much
because i know what you're going to tell
me we've got to wait for what she says
and so on but the point is
we understand her report's now going to
be laid because there are even more
parties to investigate she's going to
reinterview dominic cummings tomorrow i
understand another red wall tory mp
submitted a letter of no confidence it
really is looking pretty grim for your
government your prime minister and this
is more than a distraction it is
paralyzing you well first of all i
accept the seriousness of the issue
that's why sugree should be able to
determine who when and how she
investigates but i will point to the
decisions we made this week the success
of the vaccine roll out the measures to
open up the economy none of which would
have happened if we'd have listened to
the labour party all of which show
actually notwithstanding not your
absolutely and all of which show that
notwithstanding all of these other
issues significant as though they are
the pm is taking the right calls the big
decisions to lead us through the worst
pandemic in living memory deputy prime
minister thank you very much indeed to
talk to you
now the labour leader saqia starman was
clearly enjoying himself at prime
minister's questions this week attacking
boris johnson calling for him to resign
he was bolstered by the defection of a
tory mp and party grandi david davis
calling for the prime minister to go
well all eyes will now be on sue grey's
report into downing street parties
expected in the next few days so let's
find out how labour's going to tackle
this critical moment i'm joined by
shadow attorney general emily thornbury
good morning morning trevor um
we'll come to the party politics a
moment but i just want to start with
some of the
uh why there is news that i discussed
with deputy prime minister um
is labour satisfied that the
government's doing all it can
uh in the circumstances including having
sent weapons and personnel to ukraine
about the russian threat
i think that what's really important is
and putin knows this he has an absolute
nose for it is that we have to be
completely unified on this we have to be
strong and we have to be unified whether
it's within
nato or surrounding allies and we have
to play our part as the opposition also
in making sure that in britain we stand
unified against this threat because in
the end we putin will take advantage of
any disunity and any weakness that we
show so yes we stand with the government
on this we think that we absolutely need
to this it is outrageous the threats
that putin is making the claims that
he's trying to make in terms of telling
ukraine what it should do in the future
and we need to stand up to it but i'll
tell you what i think also
is i don't think that we use sanctions
as well as we could do i think that we
could be much more imaginative in the
way that we do there are many there is a
new generation of sanctions out there
which to be honest the proverbial
considering it well
there's a there's a power for example to
go for for for wealth that can't be
explained unexplained wealth and there
are many russian citizens in britain at
the moment who have unexplained wealth
you know we ought to be much stronger on
that we ought to be much stronger when
it comes to making sure that party
donations are completely tight we have
to make sure that that uh anybody in the
house of commons or in the lords who are
sitting on any foreign companies ought
to be on any foreign company boards or
to be or to have that register of of
interest there's a whole lot of things
that we could do in terms of tightening
up potential influence in britain but
also making sure that we are not the
laundering capital of the world i i get
all of that but um
let's be honest mr putin doesn't seem to
give much weight to appeal to his better
nature or indeed
to
financial threats to any of his friends
so what would you actually do to
forestall and invite an invasion well i
don't know about
financial threats to his friends and not
taking that seriously i don't think that
we have been particularly serious in
terms of the financial threats to the
friends i think that's the point i think
absolutely
you know if we threatened his friends we
may well be threatening his money as
well i do think this is a new generation
of sanctions this is a new way in which
you can do foreign policy very
effectively and i think that we're not
imaginative enough and we're not strong
enough in terms of the way in which we
use it okay as a shadow attorney general
what do you make of this rather
extraordinary statement by the foreign
office
naming people that it thinks could be
part of a puppet regime in kiev well we
do know that that putin has been trying
to
meddle in the affairs of ukraine for a
long time and indeed more than that you
know when he invaded part of ukraine and
we continue to have cyber attacks um in
ukraine and so therefore any attempt to
influence you know future politics and
ukraine is absolutely goes absolutely
hand in hand with that but that's why as
i said at the outset it's so important
that we are strong and that we
remain united against the threat from
putin because that's what he goes for
i'm being told that in fact the russians
have actually responded to this
statement and they call it
disinformation and uh an escalation of
tensions uh but by the west
well there we are
i mean uh sorry but i just like we just
have to stand up to these people
okay well uh
maybe uh at some point we'll we'll see
uh emily thornberry versus vladimir
putin
now i think it's the point is it's not
that the point is it may be vladimir
putin versus a united west that's what's
important
um kobed the royal college of general
practitioners uh chair says this morning
that uh forcing health staff to be
vaccinated should be delayed and it's
not the right way forward do you agree i
think that whatever we decide we got to
do we really ought to be working on the
basis of working with those within the
health service and within the union
movement so if we decide that it's a
better idea to
to to put this measure off then as i say
so long as we're working with others on
it we just need to move forward together
on this yeah but that
when we actually disagree it's not
possible to move forward that point of
politics is decide what you should do
do you do you think that those who as uh
the deputy prime minister said those who
will not be vaccinated working in the
health service because they might put
others in danger should then lose their
jobs
the principle behind that i'm afraid we
do agree with but the question is when
should that policy be implemented there
is discussion about putting off the
deadline in relation to that and and if
we're going to put off the deadline then
we need to work with the hospitals and
with the trade union movement about how
it is that we can convince as many
people as possible who work within the
health service to get themselves
vaccinated nobody works in the national
health service who doesn't come into the
service not for the money but in order
to make sure they help others and you
know and arguments need to be put before
them to say you're not helping others by
not being vaccinated all right well
let's deal with um some of the uh wider
issues that are discussed with the the
deputy prime minister the economy
particularly can i confirm that um
labor wants the government to drop its
planned rise in national insurance
and also to fed forbid any rise in the
level of the energy price cap that's
what we want to do is we want to cut vat
on on on energy because to be honest the
government has had a bit of a windfall
because you know obviously as prices go
up they get more vat out of it so we're
saying you know drop the v80 that will
that will result in hundreds of pounds
being available to families we also want
to be able to have a windfall tax on the
energy companies who themselves are also
making much greater profits as a result
and we want that money to be targeted on
the squeeze middle on the poorest on on
pensioners to make sure that they're
given assistance with their energy it's
all fully costed we're really surprised
the government doesn't have a plan but
as the opposition we're helping them out
we've got a plan we've put it on the
table we said here i'll use this
wouldn't say you're helping them out
this is a bit puzzling lab party wants
to stop attacks right that being a
percentage of income is
by its nature it's the wealthier hardest
you
want to um
stop their va their vat
change you also by the way want to keep
the bbc license fee which is a flat tax
all of these are regressive
measures i mean um when did the labour
party part of redistribution become
in favor of regressive taxation well i
don't think that the national insurance
tax is is as you as you describe i think
one of the most important things about
the national insurance tax is it is a
tax on jobs and there's a tax on
employers and if we want to have full
employment we need to make we need to
make life decisions
yeah no absolutely
but it's also a tax on it's a tax on
jobs it you know it's a it's a
disincentive for employers to take on
more people yeah this can't be right at
a time at a time like this you know
these are the reasons behind the
decisions that we've made and it's not
regressive what we've said in relation
to energy as we've said there's a two
everybody's going to have their bills
largely increased by 50
you know just in a few months time the
government just seems to be like rabbits
in the headlights just standing there
thinking oh my goodness we're about to
get run over but we what we need to do
is we need to do something about it so
we've said get rid of v80 that will help
everyone but then also have this
targeted money which would be available
for the poorest all right well look
let's um let's let's deal with uh this
is a politics show let's deal with
politics um you have uh
you know in your own way uh spent a lot
of this conversation telling me about
the shortcomings of this government um
last week your colleague where streeting
told me that you wouldn't move a vote of
no confidence because in the
in parliament because uh you didn't
think you'd have the numbers
i don't get this if he's as bad for the
nation as euro was saying he is
well first of all what does that tell
you about the parliamentary party he
leads
well look
they have a majority of 80. that's why
in the end it isn't for the opposition
to and the prime minister ought to be so
terrible not all of those conservatives
are people without conscience why can't
you bring them across to your side for
this point well we're doing our bit
we're doing our best we are making it
perfectly clear what our criticisms are
we're making the argument as to why this
prime minister is totally unfit to
continue to be at number 10 and the
latest allegations about it
we are doing our best to try and tear
them out but they do have a majority of
80 and in the end although the although
the prime minister is answerable to
parliament the parliament is skewed in
that they have a majority of 80. so
there is a great deal the prime
minister's future rests in his own
conscience he can make his own decision
but then next it is for tory mps to
decide whether or not they want to
continue to support him and we continue
to to put the argument as to why it is
and frankly so do the public i mean most
tory mps get large numbers of letters
from members of the public saying do the
right thing you know push this prime
minister out so first of all we need to
we i would i would encourage backbench
mps to put the letters in and then you
know we will hear from sue gray let's
take these things step by step all right
just very quickly uh one thing they will
always say about emily thornberry is
that she's a realist isn't the real
truth here that actually a wounded boris
johnson is better for you than boris
johnson gone without a bet with a better
leader
i think that boris johnson wounded boris
johnson full stop as prime minister does
this country no good and that's why we
want to get rid of him
emily thornberry thank you very much
indeed mata
it is eight years since russia invaded
ukraine and seized crimea in reality in
one form or another that country has
been at war ever since 13 000 ukrainians
have died as moscow-backed separatists
continue uh fighting in the east of the
country
moscow has 100 000 troops on the border
talked with nato and the u.s promised
little and in reality there's not much
western powers can do
now the uk foreign office in an
extraordinary released journalist last
night says moscow is poised to overthrow
the kiev government and install a puppet
prime minister
as it considers another full-blown
invasion
ukraine's ambassador to the uk vadim
pristiko joins me now good morning
ambassador
um
the
foreign office released this statement
we have information that indicates the
russian government is looking to install
a pro-russian leader in kiev as it
considers whether to invade and occupy
ukraine do you believe that
i do believe that it's not the first
time they're trying to do so
historically and even in recent times
and by the way all the names you
mentioned and
these people actually were helped from
ukraine to russia and they now reside in
russia by russian special services
do you actually have any evidence or do
you think that foreign office has actual
evidence of this
these people including former prime
minister mr azarov is appearing from
time to time on russian state tv talking
about the what could be achieved if he
is back in in service and even the
president yonkovic is in russia and
rastavan don so all these people are
handy at hand if they need it and that's
what russia is doing by the way they are
fighting in the courts and even london
courts for three billion euros which
they these people received from russia
in exchange not to sign the european
association agreement so all of the
things if you combine
you will see my much much but much
bigger picture you mentioned mr zarath
one of the other individuals mr moraef
has said this morning
that this claim is i'm quoting here
stupidity and nonsense he denies it
points out that he is banned from russia
so he's hardly likely to be a russian
agent
mr morale is active ukraine politician
yes with russian views but we allow this
discussion to go on in ukraine this guy
is just quite openly appears on tv he
has his own tv channel and he won't he
tells whatever he wants but i believe
that he's young politician he's also
building up his reno and that's what
he's trying to do you know appealing to
the forces in ukraine society who still
believe that soviet union and russia is
the best way for ukrainians to to
develop
do you um
and the ukrainian government
genuinely think that mr putin will
invade the ukraine
we don't just think that he would he as
you mentioned rightly not many people by
the way remember that he is already
there he is already in ukraine for all
this almost eight years so there is not
yeah there is not big news for us the
issue is how much he would bring up with
is it fully scale invasion or it is as
was mentioned discussed many many times
smaller things just you know to annoy us
and the rest of the world to show his
strengths and believe that we will back
back down
is ukraine uh prepared to fight
militarily very unfortunately we are
prepared to fight we are gathering the
forces we have times more than russians
are now keeping it our border but again
we are not that well equipped
to for the prolonged fight with russians
the um
the british i think have sent you some
weapons and some trainers um we
understand that the that germany has
decided not to do the same and indeed
has blocked uh another country from
doing so what are your feelings about
germany today
this camera is around not allowing me to
tell what i think of germany and now
right now if i have somebody from nato
to say
you know if i have somebody from nato to
tell things like that i would expect
germany to be the last ones so many
ukrainians are still remember what
germans did in our part of the globe and
ukraine especially we were talking 80 90
years ago we are talking about both of
the words worlds uh world wars and both
of them were now a part of the globe and
our lands were occupied and there is no
ukrainian family which was not not
touched by these wars
that is quite a
major accusation to throw at the current
german government that it is repeating
the treatment of ukrainians
from
the last century that's what knows not
what i said what i said is that if i
have to listen from somebody about
things like ukraine is not to be given
the weapons to defend itself the germans
would would have to stay at the very
ends of the of this long long line of
our european partners
okay you are not going to rely on
germany because you think they will will
never really come to your aid we rely on
them in economic sanctions if they are
serious with that but i don't see the
seriousness when they are still keeping
laying down the pipelines going around
our territory so would you like them for
example to um
cancel nordstream
oh absolutely that's what we ask them so
many times our pipelines allows as many
as much of the guests to come as they
want even more so there is no particular
need and we understand that each and
every nation
in nato in europe can do their part
german have
has to play some significant role if
they're not ready to provide us weapons
defensive weapons okay that we might do
something else which will help us
i'm sure that will be heard in berlin in
washington um the
u.s secretary of state anthony blinken
has been holding
talked with his russian counterpart
sergey
lavrov
what what are the ukrainian government's
red lines what does it
say to the americans you must never give
way on in these negotiations it's very
good issue because we've been talking
about this supposedly happening big deal
between russian and russians and
americans and what we were always saying
to to our american colleagues that if
you promise too much as a compromise
please be coordinating with us because
some things we won't be able to do just
for our own future something like that
like we will still go to nato and
european union this is for nato and you
to decide whether we are becoming a part
of the family but that's what we wanted
to then that's why we actually suffered
all these years not because we're
different we've been living with
russians for centuries that's because we
decided to take another model of our
development which is european
western democratic whatever the words we
will use to describe it so to for
clarity
is the ukraine's current position that
it would like to join the eu
and also at some stage nato absolutely
that's what we made clear eight years
ago and that's russia with that's why
russians came and it didn't change our
resolve even in ninj
so a clear signal to washington that
whatever you do whatever you agree do
not
agree to the russian demand that the
ukraine should not be allowed to join
nato yeah please leave it outside
outside the conversation the rockets the
forces in europe there are some things
which americans can discuss and that's
in their own power because most of these
troops are american but something which
will ukraine will suffer please
coordinate it with us first
the underlying point here is does the
west have the stomach for the fight
what what is the view in ukraine at the
moment the early in the week president
biden said the united states might
tolerate a minor incursion in ukraine
and he's retracted retracted the phrase
since then but do you
essentially believe
that when it comes to
the final decision vladimir putin
uh
and against the west that the west
has the
the stomach you know to face down putin
i believe it's getting there if you look
at all these years seven plus years when
we start asking people to help us with
some military equipment to defend
ourselves we couldn't even start this
negotiation after seven years we already
have seen the doors opened uk united
states some other nations are coming
openly to to send us weapons which not
important only as a military step but
this is political step the political
stance they are showing russians you
know what we understood it after all
these years you killed so many of the
ukraines 13 and a half thousand it's not
minor incursion anymore this is war if
you can step down please do it that's
the still chance for that
we um here are a long way away from this
and you know to some extent uh if i'm
honest and i may have been guilty of it
this morning we
uh treat mr putin as a sort of
fascinating character and
joke a bit about him but
what
what do ukrainians really feel about
this if
the diplomatic channels fail
and that there is
an invasion
um
what will the ukraine do
we have nowhere to to go i mean we
corner it in our own biggest land in
europe but still that's enough
for us and we are not inviting them to
all we will fight to this unfortunately
so many people of our nation will
probably die but we will try to get to
that world as many russians as they come
the picture that you paint what do you
think
the scale of that conflict could be how
serious could it be i i believe i still
hope that this is just threats as of now
russians might change their mind
especially putin who knows whether he's
had he might want to you know regain the
soviet union by the way it's
100th anniversary of formal formation of
soviet union this year he might come to
this particular day to love it very much
but i believe that west will with each
and every step west will you know
stiffen the spine and we'll come to to
our seasons but we're not relying to it
much we are preparing ourselves
ambassador thank you very much for time
this morning no doubt we will speak
again about this thank you thank you
back in the late summer the news was
dominated by one thing afghanistan and
the rushed chaotic
some might even say humiliating
withdrawal of western forces but has the
world now forgotten
23 million people now face one of the
harshest winters in the world with
little food hundreds of millions of
dollars of aid and assets remain blocked
former prime minister gordon brown says
the world must act and the money must
flow
he joins me now
good morning mr brown
um
let's start with afghanistan you say
it's an unfolding humanitarian disaster
uh
the aid is urgently needed
but i i suppose there will be people
watching this who will say why should we
be giving money to a country controlled
by a murderous regime that's rolling
back human rights especially for women
a hard one including
by the sacrifice of our own troops
this is a humanitarian catastrophe i
don't
forget the sacrifice of our troops and
part of the reason we were there was to
protect the afghan people
and now we face a nightmare we face a
catastrophe
it's really a moral failure because when
children are starving
and when families are emaciated and when
there is no health provision
and despite polio cholera and covid
i think we've got a duty to act now
there are self-interested reasons for
acting we want to prevent terrorists
gaining the upper hand again and
exporting the terrorism to the west
we want to prevent heroin getting to the
streets of britain we also want to
prevent mass migration and already 3
million have left afghanistan
but as ronan williams and i said in an
article yesterday there is also a duty
to help children in particular and
families with this immediate threat of
starvation itself
and this is a matter of days uh not
weeks and months if we cannot get aid to
people they will die in front of our
eyes and we've already seen tv uh
pictures of children so emaciated that
they will not survive
so it's humanitarian and i don't think
anybody any father any mother in the
world would say that when children are
in this difficulty we should fail to act
what we've got to do is find a way
around this that does not legitimize the
regime that gives them no credibility
for the aid that we're giving gets the
money through the ngos and through the
united nations organizations and make
sure it's absolutely clear that the help
is being provided by people who have
wanted to help the people of afghanistan
over the last 20 years
i'm sure a powerful case can be made
morally for this but you yourself have
just raised the
point uh when you talked about getting
the money to ngos how can we be sure
that that money is going to get
to the places where it's needed and
where people can be fed and sheltered
and kept safe over winter
well i'm already chairman of the
education canada weight organization
that helps refugees and displaced people
and you are able and unicef is being
able to do this to make informal
arrangements at a local level
where you can pay the salaries of
teachers and health workers and at the
same time make sure girls can go to
school and make sure that people are
actually fed so there are ways at the
moment martin griffis the humanitarian
coordinator for the united nations
is showing that through the united
nations the world bank and through many
ngos we can actually get aid to people
the problem is
uh that there is an appeal now for four
and a half billion dollars
that's urgently needed for the 23
million people that you talked about to
prevent them starving and only a quarter
of that money has been raised now there
were 40 countries in the coalition in
afghanistan
what i'm suggesting and there is a
petition now circulating through save
the children asking the british public
to support this what i'm suggesting is
that britain and the european union call
a humanitarian conference bring the 40
countries together get the money in make
sure it's actually going to the starving
children and to the families in need but
all that can be done but the money has
not been raised and one of the reasons
i'm making this appeal this morning with
the churches and faith groups who've
signed a letter also
is that i believe the british public can
ask the government to pay attention to
this call the conference get this done
and of course there are talks starting
with the taliban in norway today and
first on the agenda will be this issue
of humanitarian aid getting through
without giving credibility to the regime
itself
you um of course are able to make this
appeal because you've been for many
years um amongst world leaders and
you've been at all of the conferences
and talks and so on so forth um
the big issue that would occupy those
conversations today of course is ukraine
um
do you actually think anything is going
to come from the talks with vladimir
putin about ukraine
well let me say first of all the same
principle applies to afghanistan as as
ukraine you do need leadership you need
people to act together you do need unity
and one of the problems in afghanistan
is we need a country to lead this
humanitarian effort and to call the
conference
i think the same applies in ukraine
president putin will exploit any
weakness
any failure to show strength and in
particular any failure to show unity
will give
a blank check if you like
to continued aggression
now we know that the demands he's making
are completely unreasonable he wants to
remove weapons from members of nato's
soils he wants to prevent sweden and
finland ever join ever joining nato
he wants uh the
nato countries to say that they will not
enlist any countries in the future now
he's making unreasonable demands and of
course the only way to deal with that
because if you exceed to one you'll
simply get another set of demands on top
of them
is to show strength and that's why
i think what emily thornbe said this
morning is really important that you've
got to have a united west and a united
set of allies
and of course that is something that is
in question this weekend and again i
think britain america and the western
allies have got to come together and
show that they are completely agreed on
the need for sanctions that they will be
financial they'll be economic they'll be
targeted on individual uh people
we will not hesitate to apply them
quickly
and i think that message has got to go
out without any uh danger that there is
not unanimity
paul volcker the senior american
diplomat who i'm pretty sure you will
know said last week that that
program that you've just outlined would
be the right thing to do but even so he
did not think
that it would prevent
a russian invasion because if that's
what mr putin wants to do that's what he
wants to do it's what he will do and
nothing we can do can stop him
well you know we know that president
putin wants to declare a sphere of
influence that extends way beyond the
borders of russia itself
we know you'd he would prefer to have a
different government in ukraine one that
is
in his own hands although i'm not sure
about all this information this morning
about uh the particular names
they don't seem to add up uh but
the important thing is that he i i've
met him on a number of occasions i've
dealt with him i've had to stand up to
him when we had the assassination on
british soil
but he's an opportunist he probably does
not himself know what he's going to do
next we know what he wants to do the
question is what he will do the
important thing is at this particular
point in time and there's going to be
discussions the defense secretary is
going to moscow there's letters
exchanging between america and the
the russians
at this point we've got to show strength
and that's i think what was
uh something of uh an issue in the last
few days when it wasn't clear what the
germans were doing the french were
talking about a separate or appear to be
talking about a separate deal that was a
european deal with russia and of course
uh there is this issue about energy
prices and what is actually going to
happen if the flow of gas continues to
slow to the west uh all these issues are
going to be taken into account but the
important thing is got to have a show of
strength you you said you weren't that
sure about the uh intelligence which has
been published today do you think the
foreign office is um i mean it's very
unusual for the foreign office to
publish this kind of of intelligence do
you think they've overstepped the mark
here
well i've no doubt that uh president
putin would prefer to establish
a friend of his as he had before in
control in ukraine and i've no doubt
that he has possible people in mind if
he was ever to be in this position
but the names that have been given don't
necessarily seem to add up
but that's not the real issue the real
issue is can you get the allies together
can nato show its power and its strength
as a unified force
and can we force
the russians to back down and i think
you know from my knowledge of president
uh putin he's an adventurist as well as
an opportunist
but you must not give him an inch if
you're going to stand up to russian
aggression
okay but by my reckoning gordon brown i
don't think there's anybody who has been
in
downing street alive longer than you
have as chancellor and then prime
minister um
what do you make of the chaos that is
engulfing downing street right now and
um can you imagine the kind of thing
that we are reading about taking place
on your watch
well
this is indeed about standards in public
life look we we know the government is
immobilized and and despite what dominic
rob says
the attention that is needed for the
cost of living crisis
for the schools for people to catch up
as children in schools uh for obviously
afghanistan for ukraine
for all the problems that are besetting
the health service
the attention has veered uh towards
dealing with these particular scandals
and and my fear is that scandal is going
to follow boris johnson as long as he's
prime minister
you know we don't just have the scandal
and all the details will probably come
out later this this week about partying
we have
the conflicts of interest we have the
dubious appointments we have foreign
money and question marks over that who's
paying the bills for what and i don't
think we're going to see this
administration end in anything other
than scandal
are you saying to me that you think
looking at the current prime minister
that this is not a man with either the
character or the moral stature
to occupy
the position of prime minister of this
country
i i think it's about standards in public
life i'm i'm not going to comment on
boris johnson as an individual but but
it is about standards in public life and
the minute the public realize
that governments are asking
uh their uh citizens to follow rules
that they're not prepared to follow
themselves
and the minute you have a question mark
over behavior and conduct in in in
public life
that is indeed very serious because when
you're dealing with a pandemic and now
with an economic cost of living's crisis
the most important thing you need is
that people are prepared to trust the
the leaders to get things right and
trust them to do things even when
they're unpopular to get the right
answers in the long run so this is
really an ethical issue it's about the
conduct of public life
having said that the phrase that is
going around this week is
fish rots from the head
very many people have said this is not
for me to make a judgment
many people have said that this kind of
thing would never have happened with
theresa may david cameron
tony blair
or gordon brown in number 10 because you
set
an example
do you think
that it is time
for mr johnson if that is true
to go
and to have someone who will set the
right standards and the right kind of
leadership both of which you've
mentioned this morning
well trevor you know i came on to talk
about afghanistan and about uh the
humanitarian issues and i feel that
boris johnson should be dealing with us
and i i don't want to make this simply
about a person i think it's the
character of the government that is at
issue it's the standards in public life
and if i were him i would be sure to say
that we're going to have a massive
review of all rules governing public
life in this country because clearly you
cannot run downing street the way it's
been run
you cannot make appointments in the way
they've been made
and you cannot allow the sort of
behavior that is that has happened and
hope somehow the public will not notice
when you're asking them to take
decisions that you're not prepared to
take
themselves look sue grey has got a
report on the the present uh issues
all right you're you're quite you're
quite right to say let's let's focus on
the things that matter and if i before i
let you go can i just ask you one
specific thing which probably you would
know
about better than anybody else in the
world you were the last person to hike
national insurance do you think that
chancellor should go ahead with that or
should it be delayed as
many people are suggesting
well i'm not convinced that national
insurance is the right uh tax to deal
with the problems that we're facing
social care in particular
and i think kyosama is right you've got
to look at people's standards of living
as a whole and what costs they're going
to have to bear look i'm a patron of a
charity in fife and we're dealing with
poverty that i have not seen in my
lifetime
we're dealing with people who can't heat
their homes we're dealing with children
who are not going to school well clad
and going to school hungry
and we're dealing with a crisis among so
many people because they are demoralized
and facing mental health problems as a
result of what has happened as a result
of this crisis now to impose upon those
families
an energy price rise in the heating
bills and in their electricity
then to impose a tax rise for those who
are paying
national insurance
at a time when food prices are also
rising at the same time and you've had
this 20 pounds cut in people's universal
credit it is simply not acceptable
and the the devastating effect on
poverty it will be seen very quickly if
all these things go ahead so kirsten has
been right to say we've got to focus on
what the living standards are of people
at the moment and how they're going to
be cut if we don't act
gordon brown thank you so much for your
time this morning
thank you
now as england moves back to plan a
pupils will no longer have to wear masks
this term all schools are expected to
offer face-to-face teaching to every age
group and online learning for those who
are absent or isolating
the children's commissioner for england
is worried about the thousands of
children who have fallen off the radar
during lockdown so as we move into
living with kovid mode just what has
been the impact on our children and
their education
i'm joined now by rachel d'souza
children's commissioner good morning
dave morning trevor morning
um now this week the prime ministers
told schools in england to end the
wearing face mask some teaching unions
and heads are pretty cross about that
this they think it's premature um
where do you stand who's right
look i think i when i came into post in
march april i did a survey of england's
children and we got over half a million
responses the largest survey of children
in england done four to
eighteen-year-olds from every part of
the country and you know what children
told me they told me they wanted to get
back to school they wanted to deal with
their mental health mental well-being
issues they wanted to catch up
and they really and the reason they
wanted to do this was their great
ambition for their own futures they want
great jobs great careers and to create
families of their own um i have been
down so from that i wanted to put
children at the heart of recovery from
the pandemic now i've been at the school
gates and talking to colleagues and what
children are telling me is masks or not
masks we want to be back at school it's
great to be back great to be together
great to be doing extracurricular things
now my worry is the large number of
children who are not back and that's
what we should be focusing on now i have
to come to that if i may in a second but
do you think that the
lifting of the mask mandate
is going to help in that aim that you
set out or not
so i think um
we focused a lot on masks but and and i
think a lot of children find it very
hard to wear a mask all day some are
anxious and want to wear them i actually
think the key thing is that they want to
be back at school and we should be
looking at attendance because if you're
not at school you can't learn and you
can't recover
all right well look the um the signs are
that we are moving from pandemic to
endemic so
in some way we're moving to that new
normal cycle lockdowns is over
um but
you've been saying that the price that
children have had to pay is very high
and you're now
looking at this
this problem of children going off the
radar i mean um
what what what is the cause of that and
what's the scale of it
yeah so i think the scale is huge
normally normally around this time 95 of
children would be in school looking at
the figures last week
it was 87
that's you know with about 8.9 million
children in england that's a huge amount
of children now what children are
telling me is that that some of them are
not in for mental health concerns
they're not getting those met quickly
enough and the treatment they need
for some special educational needs for
some it's truancy but there's another
group as well um and that group are not
even on rolls um i was in a police
county um
recently and they showed me they had a
list of children that they've come
across who are not on anyone's roles so
what i've done is called ten
i've got data gathering powers and the
first thing i've done is called ten
local authorities together and asked
them some basic questions i did an
initial data sweep and ask them simply
how many children have you got in your
area how many are not at school how many
are waiting for school places and they
could not all answer those questions so
i've now written to all 141 local
authority and
authorities i'm working with dfe and
with schools
for me
we need to do a number of things we need
to sort out the data and make sure that
the management information is coming
right through and we can help with that
and i'm pushing um i'm working with
local authorities and pushing the
department for education to do something
about that it's 2022 our data systems
can deal with that but also we need to
be listening to children and i'm going
to make sure in those 10 areas and
across the country we really get to the
bottom of what children need to get back
to school so they can thrive
okay before
we
and i do want to pick up the point that
you raised about children's mental
health
to what extent do you think this is
merely a dip um a problem
about the changed circumstances we've
been living in for the next uh last two
years i beg your pardon from which we'll
recover and to what extent do you think
something
fundamental has changed that will affect
this cohort of school children
so before i did my survey i would have
gone with your form of you um you know
it's been a difficult time it's it's a
well-being issue and if we get everyone
back it'll be fine but but the response
to
the big ass survey was overwhelming um
it was the number one issue that
children are telling me that they need
to thrive and that's right across the
country we got responses from every
single local authority area and the
number one issue was mental health and
mental well-being and so i think it's
extremely serious and we need to really
make sure that that children are getting
the treatment they need and i've been
talking to such a javid and getting and
looking at the nhs's plans to deal with
children's mental health i think i think
it really is very serious indeed
uh damn rachel d'souza thank you very
much indeed
thank you
well that's it from uh the main program
this morning in a little while after the
break i'll be talking to sam coates
we'll be back next week no doubt with
latest moves on the ukraine border who
knows what mr putin's going to do uh
there may be peace there but i'm pretty
sure there's not going to be peace in
downing street or over in westminster
more next sunday
[Music]